welcome back to PE Mor uncensored live
from my sitting room where I've got
covid so I'm doing the show from home uh
but I'm joined by my pack talk Tov
contributor Esther krku and the podcast
from comedian James Barber welcome to
both of you right I want to talk Taylor
Swift who today was named Time
magazine's person of the year beating
off a lot of people from Vladimir Putin
Vladimir zeny you know you could you
could put all sorts of world leaders in
the mix um but she uh was the winner
Esther are you a Taylor Swift fan should
she have got this Accolade and what does
it mean about her status in the panth of
Pop Idols well I'm not a Taylor swi fan
just because I feel like if she was a
man she wouldn't get away with singing
about her exes in the way that she does
I find a uh very very uh like a drunk
white girl's dream oh come off do that
time sorry I just you know it's weird
but she does deserve her success she is
now officially a billionaire her her
tour has raked in so much money I mean
her tour has created many economic
bubbles in areas that um she's actually
performed so that that is a feat of her
own but I do think it says more about
society that this is the person that's
uh the woman of the year than uh well
person of the year than than anyone else
I would personally go someone else but
well you see all right well let me bring
in James now James you and I have locked
horns about Madonna many times but on
this we may find some agreement because
I actually think Taylor Swift she's a
brilliant singer songwriter I mean one
of the best there's been she is a
fantastic role model I mean you know you
could if you had a young daughter you
would love her to be a swift because she
represents all that's wholesome and good
about the world right not some of the
idols some of some of these rap stars um
but let me finish with James but but
James but she's also turned out to be an
incredibly Savvy businesswoman I mean
she's generating vast amounts of cash
more I was told by someone in La she
makes more money than the Beatles prata
did right so there is a legitimate
argument she's now the biggest pop star
there's ever been
right I mean she's on 200 billion I
think U Madonna is on total sales of 300
billion Madonna has kind of hit her Peak
and I saw the celebration tour last
night it was slay but I think we
swifties know that Taylor Swift is not
really even at her Peak yet and is only
just emerging into that Peak period and
the ER is tour is almost a best of so w
what is next Taylor Swift is just an
icon and Esther I really think you need
to spend some time healing your heart
and listening to midnight because I know
from off air CH we've both been going
through a little bit of a difficult time
you need some Taylor away what I would
say I would say this to Esther if if
James Bar and me agree about something
it is so unprecedented that you really
ought to join the party
yeah I'm sorry Taylor Swift's dating
history is a complete dumpster fire if I
if she was my friend I would be like
ma'am we we need to talk um you need to
take a long break and stop singing about
your X is it's not cute strange it no
she listen Taylor can do whatever the
hell she wants and actually it is cute
because she is finally breaking the
patriarchal boundaries and saying you
know what women are allowed to express
their feelings it's actually so
patriarchal I can't believe you're the
Piers Morgan on the pi Morgan show right
now Esther because literally Taylor
Swift is breaking bound she's calling
out
a well I don't know about the he never
felt I've never felt so rough doing it I
can tell you that oh yeah you win some
some here's the point Esther I would
make about her is that I I read an
amazing stat that not only did she sell
out this tour around the world to huge
stadiums night after night but the
merchandise average spend per fan who
bought a ticket was over
$230 ahead per person you could give me
her tickets for free I and then she then
she released a movie of the of the
concert and that was one of the biggest
movie hits of the year I mean everything
she touches is is gigantic well she is
good model she well the thing is her
brand is very is is is genius right
because she's very relatable she is
literally every drunk white girl's dream
she has terrible relationships she's not
perfect she's not hasn't had great
relationship thing she hasn't had a lot
of surgery done she is just AAL word to
J all right hang on don't talk over each
other final word to James she's got a
hunky new football star boyfriend she's
got it all now right yeah she's walking
around with her next album ready to go
when that relationship may or may not
end but Taylor Swift is an icon she's
amazing I love her so much Esther I
don't know what music you're listening
to but it might be time to all right we
got to wrap it up James let's end while
you're on a high we agree Esther you're
wrong that's it for
tonight